in that shot really was an amazing
feeling it it hit
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's January 18 2023 we are live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
if you want to play along during the
show and watch our post game wrap-up
show go to
reubenreport.locals.com and the theme
today is a real continuation it is a
part two of where we left off yesterday
it is a destruction of what is going on
over there at the world economic forum
and I I would say an analysis of the
crazy type of people that think that
they should own your life I don't think
I should own your life I think maybe I
could talk about some of these issues in
a way that helps you understand what the
important issues are more and perhaps
gives you some of the tools to live your
life as you see fit but there are
globalist people globalist forces out
there like John Kerry and Bill Gates and
a whole bunch of other people obviously
Klaus Schwab guy and many others who
think that they have the as John Kerry
put it the other day extraterrestrial
knowledge to sit down with other very
rich Elite people and eat very very
fancy foods and decide how you you
should live your life I don't like it I
don't like them and we're gonna destroy
them today that's the plan uh real quick
before we get to it let's talk about
bullion Max you guys know that 2022 was
the worst year for the stock market
since 2008. so what does 2023 hold and
do you really want all your eggs in that
basket I recommend you get Diversified
in your assets and you can do just that
with booleanmax.com Dave at
booleanmax.com Dave you can buy physical
gold and silver bars and coins and
they'll ship them directly to your home
fully insured there you can store them
in your safe for a time you might really
need it you have fire extinguishers at
your house that are easy to reach to
prevent the house from burning down or
at least hope you do you hope you never
have to use one but you should be
grateful when you have one when the
worst should happen what if your
financial house burns down if paper
money becomes worthless if the stock
market completely collapses wouldn't it
be nice to have something for
emergencies start building your Reserve
at booleanmax.com Dave we put together a
silver starter kit just for you listen
to this you're going to get a solid one
ounce silver American Eagle a buffalo
round even a one ounce silver kangaroo
this is the best way to get started with
diversifying your savings go to
bullionmax.com Dave today and now back
to me okay so connected to what's going
on at the world economic forum and we're
going to show you some video of the
weirdos at Davos uh is the sort of
global freak out over climate change
my position on climate change is
something like this the climate has
always been changing it is possible I
suppose that humans have had some effect
on the climate that is possible but my
broader feeling about climate change is
that if you think that mental midgets
like AOC and the rest of these people
can put policies in place that somehow
we're going to stop the climate from
changing
I'd like to sell you a bridge which you
probably will have you buying soon
enough it'll be a green bridge and it
won't really work it'll probably be a
bridge to nowhere but that's where
they're going to move on yet anyway all
of this is connected to climate change
and you can feel sort of you know
whether it's we want to take your gas
stoves away we don't want you to drive
this car you guys shouldn't uh you know
we're going to fly in private planes
while you while we tell everybody that
their carbon footprint is too much all
of this stuff
um this is deeply connected to this
little girl Greta funberg we all know
about Greta thundberg how dare you Greta
thundberg uh well yesterday
she was in Germany at a climate protest
and she got arrested we have video of
her arrest this is serious stuff she was
arrested by German police very serious
stuff people Greta thundberg arrested by
German police in Germany scary here we
go
wow that seems like serious stuff I mean
these climate protesters they're out
there they're protesting because they
want to save the world clearly we humans
are a problem for the world and the
climate and all that stuff so they
arrested her it was at a coal mine in
gar's Wheeler Germany they were
protesting whatever's going on over
there at the coal mine but as you can
see they're carrying her away this seems
very very horrible uh could it be
possible though that maybe this was all
a hoax could be that someone else was
taking video a little bit before that
and hot diggity dog
[Laughter]
you also want those for you guys
welcome
bye
I mean
it all Bs
I'm doing Joe Biden right now I'm
whispering to you guys because I'm
telling you really what's going on
that's what Joe Biden does when he
really wants to make a point it's all
engaged BS I mean literally the police
officers there who were carrying her
away and holding her arms by her wrists
they are staging pictures with her
smiling before that that first clip of
her being hauled away of course that
gets millions and millions of views it
travels across the internet and people
look at it the young social justice
Warrior sees that and they go gosh darn
it they're going after Greta thundberg
again I love Greta thundberg you see the
evil State the Germans and the powers
that be on capitalism and in reality it
is all staged nonsense okay so let's
that's I thought was the right place to
start today but it's going to continue
on its way we're going to go from
Germany to Davos it's not that far of a
ride actually but we're that's where
we're going to take it but before we get
to Davos uh Bill Gates and you guys know
Bill Gates as I always say he did create
Windows on Microsoft it was the
operating system of the 80s they had the
paint I always bring up paint what else
do they have on Windows
but they have Minesweeper they had
Minesweeper that's one of those little
you know you got a DOT you got to move a
box or something all right so he did
some stuff and of course the Windows
operating system which is basically you
know subsequently they released many
versions of it it fell apart do you ever
you'd have a million viruses very odd
that he creates something that has
viruses on it
you see what I'm saying uh anyway Bill
Gates who is now the number one Farmland
owner in the United States has thousands
and thousands of Farmland here in the
United States he has houses all over the
world right on the water
including his like 30 million dollar
mansion in Seattle right on the water
you'd think he'd be freaking out because
the climate change in the water and all
that stuff but don't worry about Bill
Gates uh he was interviewed by Anderson
Cooper now Anderson Cooper I actually
think relative to what goes on generally
at CNN Anderson Cooper is sort of just
nothing right he's not horrific I guess
he's not good you know he's part of the
whole thing but he's not like just balls
out horrible okay uh he interviewed Bill
Gates and he actually asked him about
Bill Gates carbon footprint because as
you know Bill Gates is flying all over
the place his private planes all of the
stuff that he's always talking about but
doesn't seem to really live in a in a
congruent way in his own life with those
things take a look are you the right
Messenger on this because you fly
private plans a lot and you're creating
a lot of greenhouse gases yourself yeah
I'd probably have one of the highest
greenhouse gas Footprints of anyone on
the planet you know my my personal
flying uh alone is gigantic cake now I'm
spending quite a bit uh to buy aviation
fuel that was made with plants you know
I switched to an electric car I've used
solar panels
unpainted company that actually at a
very high price can pull a bit of carbon
out of the air and stick it underground
and so I'm offsetting my personal
emissions don't worry guys he's taking
carbon out of the air and putting it
underground how do you think that's
going to work out like probably not that
well right they're putting all the
carbon underground and then in five
years from now we're going to find out
boy you put a lot of carbon underground
it blows a whole bunch of [ __ ] up
he's just a complete hip-hop He's a
hypocrite I was going to try to come up
with something a little more clever
there he's a hypocrite and and an
authoritarian control freak first off I
don't believe that he's offsetting
somehow he has figured out through plant
stuff that he puts in his planes that he
has somehow offset his carbon footprint
you have to understand that this guy
with the amount of houses that he owns
the amount of land that he owns the
planes that he is on I don't begrudge
him any of those things either by the
way as I always say like I am a
capitalist he created something it has
value I don't like the fact that he then
takes all of his money to decide how the
rest of us should live but the idea that
he is somehow offset his carbon
footprint which he admits is gigantic
but good for him he's got an electric
car and solar panels uh the problem is
that he's trying to push all of those
things on everyone else and not everyone
can afford those things that is the
problem but let's contrast him with
another billionaire because they're not
all evil control freaks let's contrast
him with Elon Musk who knows a little
bit about electric cars himself Elon
Musk in February of 2021 was on Joe
Rogan's podcast and Rogan asked him what
is the deal what's the deal with Bill
Gates
explain to me what Bill Gates was
talking about when he was saying that
you can't do trucks
what was yeah he didn't know what we're
talking about why did he say that then
like why would someone probably somebody
told him that and you know he's just
repeated it he's just not that close to
the physics of it and so it was because
I don't think he's real intentioned here
he just doesn't know what he's talking
about but why say it then you think
about a guy who's so involved in
technology you would think you would
only talk about things you understand
I don't know it's weird I also heard
that at one point he had a big short
position against Tesla which was kind of
I don't know if that's true or not but
it seems weird
uh people I know who know know the
situation well they they said are you
sure they said yeah he's a big short
position against Tesla which obviously
didn't work out too well
the short version of that whole
conversation is Bill Gates is involved
in a whole bunch of things that he is
not an expert in there is no reason that
you nor I or anyone you know should be
listening to Bill Gates when it comes to
climate or covid or anything else he's a
tech guy he's a tech guy and again
without the glibness he did create
Windows okay that's great he did do that
he created Microsoft huge company made a
lot of money that's just fine but
somehow he has weaseld his way into
every facet of American life this is a
problem so now let's link that to what's
going on over there at the world
economic Forum because they've got
everybody freaking out over climate
change one of the things that Bill Gates
and Greta thundberg and John Kerry are
always talking about that if you guys
just would give up some of your stuff
that they would have enough power to
stop the climate uh I suspect that's not
really true here is a video from the
world economic Forum yesterday here's a
bunch of speakers and they are trying to
freak you the F out when it comes to
climate change and what's happening on
planet Earth
dear friends
scientifically this is not a climate
crisis
we are now facing something deeper mass
extinction air pollution undermining
ecosystem functions
really putting Humanity's future at risk
this is a planetary crisis
this is a safety crisis but above all it
is also a Justice crisis
oh shut up I have just had it with these
people everything is going to be fine
guys I mean I do realize we have to like
ruin these people's lives and get them
out of our way but like the planet is
going to be just fine things might
change a little bit and you know okay
water might rise like some of those
things might all be possible and I
actually believe the jury is out on
those things if there was ever a show to
cancel me I want to be this one because
these people freak out unless you bow to
their climate Gods I just refuse to do
it but humans always find a way Jeff
Goldblum Jurassic Park life finds a way
okay we're gonna be okay or we should be
looking into other things things like
things that are Elon Musk is doing like
uh I don't know maybe go to Mars if you
think it's so terrible here but they
don't seem to be focused on that they
seem to be focused on what we can do to
control people here on planet Earth okay
so they're freaking out mass extinction
is coming
mass extinctions coming I got a mass
extinction for you people uh here's a
tweet from Elon Musk about what's going
on right now over at the world economic
Forum he was responding uh to Scott
Adams you guys know Scott Adams he's
been on the show many times the creator
of Dilbert uh Elon said would be great
if someone could compile a game contest
of who said the craziest stuff between
4chan and the world economic for uh the
world economic Forum my money is on the
ladder if you guys don't know what
Fortune is I swear to you I have never
once been on Fortune have you guys ever
been on board yet I have never once but
for Chan from what I understand is
basically like the true like underbelly
sewage system of the internet where like
all the crazies say the craziest
nonsense and then unfortunately it seems
like a whole bunch of It kind of bubbles
up to mainstream but the idea that that
elon's even making that comparison like
if you took like the craziest place on
the internet where the wackiest ideas
from like the nuttiest people are shared
that's sort of comparable to what's
going on at the world economic Forum
right now like these people are really
really out of control and as I said on
Fox this morning and I was on Dana
Perino's show America's Newsroom on Fox
this morning it's interesting because
when you watch these people John Kerry
Klaus Schwab whoever it might be it's
interesting that no one seems to
represent themselves or their country
people only seem to represent these
ideas they represent climate change
right they represent all of the policies
that they want to impose on you but why
is John Kerry never talking about what's
good for the United States while he is
there why is he not talking about what's
good for the individual I think you know
the answer to that question uh but let's
continue here is the UN Secretary
General and he's basically telling
politicians you've got to shut these
people up because you're better than
them so go home to your country and be
better than them for God's sakes but
politicians need to understand
and sometimes we are faced with these
kind of challenges
it is better
to take today decisions that will
eventually be not popular but it will be
essential
to be able to shape the public opinion
itself
you better you politician you better be
able to take our ideas and take them
home and shape opinion you better be
able to otherwise you won't be back next
year and you won't have the foie gras
and you won't have the pate and you
won't have the caviar so they this is
what they're doing I mean this is what
the whole plan of this meeting is to do
is to get all of these people together
and then send them back to their
satellite States and use the ideas that
they have implanted in these people so
that they will actually actively work
against the interests of their own
people now we do have some Americans
there this image is a good one how about
this we do have some Americans uh I as I
said do they represent America it's very
curious to me uh this is from Greg price
who's a journalist and says quite the
image the senator from West Virginia
speaking at the world economic Forum in
Switzerland while wearing a Ukraine
label a lapel pin uh of course as you
guys know that is Joe manchin who is
thought of as sort of like the one
somewhat sane Democrat right because
he's not like a complete walkster
Progressive nut bag but he is sitting in
Davos in Switzerland at a globalist
event and he is not even wearing the pin
of the United States he is wearing the
pin of Ukraine and you know there is no
chance in high hell that he would have
worn an American flag there on his lapel
you know that nobody would wear an
American flag on their lapel there and
that is a problem so somehow the climate
thing the globalist thing the covid
thing the Ukraine thing they're all
connected they're all connected that's
not crazy conspiracy stuff that's like
basic truth that we are now trying to
put that puzzle together as I often talk
about these things
we've got all the pieces right in front
of us they're telling us the plans
they're wearing the pins they're doing
all the stuff but we just don't know
exactly what that puzzle is fully
supposed to look like so we have to keep
putting the pieces together but normally
when you make when you do a puzzle you
know what you're trying to make we're
trying to figure that whole thing out I
think we're a whole bunch of us are
getting a lot closer to it now here is
the most ironic ridiculous thing going
on at the world economic Forum this one
when I saw the picture of this yesterday
I actually thought it was fake it is so
ridiculous it is so profoundly
buffoonish that I was like this cannot
possibly be real you are not going to
believe this sit back lock yourself in
your chair don't have coffee in your
mouth while you're watching this because
you might do a spit take get this one
guys Brian stelter
the potato-like Brian stelter who got
fired from CNN for being such a hack
joke a guy who pushed every hoax Jessie
Smollett Russia very fine people on both
sides Brett Kavanaugh is a serial rapist
we can go through the Litany of all of
them the Covington kids Kyle Rittenhouse
all of the hoaxes all of the covid
nonsense he has been on the wrong side
of every issue and got fired from CNN
for it okay
that's how bad this guy is and was it
his job so what happens you get fired
from your job at CNN in the media doing
a show called reliable sources which as
I always said if they would have just
titled it unreliable sources it would
have made a hell of a lot more sense and
I would have shut up about it he gets
fired from his job at CNN and then as
I've told you before he then gets a job
teaching at Harvard University about the
media okay so you fail you utterly fail
you have no fan base no one respects you
or likes you but then you fell up and
this is what I talk about when I'm about
Progressive privilege or democrat
privilege you can ruin absolutely
everything you can be horrible at your
job and you will be pushed up the
machine because you will just continue
to give the machine What It Wants Gavin
Newsom you destroy San Francisco so you
get pushed up the machine now you can
destroy California and I think his
ultimate goal will be to destroy the
United States okay fine that's how this
thing works so stelter fired at C CNN he
gets a job at Harvard and now
now he is hosting a misinformation panel
at the world economic forum do we have a
barf bag do we have barf bags in the
studio we're in a barf bags here find me
some sort of thing that I can possibly
barf in Brian stelter
the clear and present danger of
disinformation is our conversation here
this afternoon it follows a session just
now about disrupting distrust and of
course those are connected so I hope
that's where we can start I'm Brian
stelter formerly of CNN now a fellow at
Harvard University we can try to put
some real information out into the world
to make up for all the crazy I'll tell
you a brief funny maybe not funny story
so I leave CNN
with regards to 2016 and and Trump's
showing that lying Works has has that
only become more true in the in the last
six years do you see evidence that it's
less true hopefully now but haven't we
seen many Democrats in the last six
years pressuring Facebook and Twitter
and now Tick Tock to be stronger in
content moderation uh hasn't that been a
wave that we've seen crash over for
years now well I think this is the
question of you know I mean ultimately
what we're trying to to achieve there is
some measure of Public Safety right we
we're not uh I mean sure there are some
politicians who are going to go out and
just get angry at Facebook if they see
things that are mean the difference is
when you know I have a constituency that
I'm trying to keep healthy and I can't
get them to take a coveted vaccine
because of misinformation that's
propagated on the internet
this is so extraordinary at so many
levels first off to bring Brian stelter
really you could argue he is like the
number one guy if you if you looked up
misinformation in the dictionary it
should have his picture so they they
take the guy who was like the guy on
misinformation and then he's asking
these bureaucrats about misinformation
and they're defending the misinformation
that he pushed in other words he was
pushing all of the covid VAC stuff he
was pushing all of the Mandate stuff and
they're still making it seem like people
who are anti-vaxx or who were skeptical
of the vaccines or who didn't want
mandates that we are all still the bad
guys no no no you are the bad guys uh
Stelzer continued because one of the
other things that these people do is
they they are horrible at their job they
spread misinformation they accuse you of
what they are doing and then when they
get called on out on it they have to
pretend that they are the victim because
nothing is higher in the hierarchy of
lunacy than victimhood to these pathetic
buffoons so stelter here he is he's a
victim I'll tell you a brief funny maybe
not funny story so I leave CNN and
there's a crazy website that posts an
article saying I was arrested by
military police and then I have a fact
checking email and I don't know whether
to reply to the fact Checker and bother
with this right same website a month
later says I've been executed at
Guantanamo Bay so the fact Checker
emails me again and I say well do you
want to take my pulse how do I disprove
that I wasn't executed and so to me that
is that is amusing and ridiculous poor
guy he has to respond to emails about
whether
God says you know I said to the guys
during the clip you know yesterday I
said that Al Gore seems to be filled
with jelly I think they're really
stuffing stelter with jelly what's
what's going on with these people the
other thing that really is bizarre about
stelter and it proves when I talk about
these people who just give the system
that they want stelter is also not
talented in any way right like he
doesn't look like he should be on
television he sounds listening to him is
quite grating right
it's like what is it about him that the
machine loves the machine loves that he
blows the machine endlessly and the
Machine like a lot of people would like
to be blown endlessly that really is
basically where we're at
there's some blow jelly thing here all
right whatever here's uh Vera girova of
the European commission uh and she I
mean this is really extraordinary this
woman is not an American she is from the
European commission uh and she's hinting
that the U.S has hate speech laws coming
for hate speech well we need the people
who understand the language and the case
law in the country because what
qualifies as hate speech as illegal hate
speech which you will have soon also in
U.S I think that
no [ __ ] we won't
Over My Dead Body I'm sorry guys I'm
trying to do a highbrow show I really do
my goal every day every day I swear on
my life is to do the most highbrow show
possible and then I watch these clips
once before we do the show and then I
watch them live with you and I don't
know what else to say but no [ __ ] we
will not have hate speech laws here we
have the First Amendment and stelter
sitting there smiling as well yes and
the other guy oh yes we will have a
you're horrible people we're going to
stop you let's continue uh CNN
which is where Brian's Delta used to
work uh is having a tough time of it
right now uh not only of course you know
they got rid of their old they fired a
whole bunch of people including stelter
then they got rid of Jeff Zucker who was
running the network into the ground they
you know Pro they danced out Don Lemon
to say that they're they're not liberal
you know they just they're just doing it
right down the middle all this nonsense
no one's paying attention no one's
watching anymore so they don't know what
to do now they're reversing things they
want to bring some of the partisan
people back they just don't know what's
going on over there but one of the
things that they're really really
struggling with is the fact that the
internet exists that's what so much of
this is about in the old days if if
media companies lied to us and maybe
they've been lying to us for 70 years
right maybe since the Advent of
Television you go to Radio before that
and you go to the printing press before
that maybe the journalist and the
information Peddlers were always lying
about everything I'm not quite sure
that's the case I think it has gotten
much much worse in the in the age of the
internet and everything else but the
real issue here is that as places like
CNN lie about virtually everything the
reason that they are always doing these
panels on misinformation and
disinformation and why they like the
government collusion on speech is
because the internet exists and on the
internet people can clip video and you
can watch them lie in real time you can
expose their lives you can point out
when they say Donald Trump said this but
you know they said that he said that and
you can also and this is the key part
and that's where we're about to do a
destruction of one of these people one
of the other things you can do is you
can go back and watch what they did when
they lied in real time so here is a
panel of CNN this is yesterday finally
admitting that covid deaths and
hospitalizations were over counted now
the guests that they are going to have
on there's three hosts the guest is
lyanna Nguyen lyanna Wu lyanna Wu you
guys remember really Adam she was one of
the biggest coveted fear mongers for
mandates locking people in their houses
and all of that stuff okay yet she's the
guest now as they talk about how covet
hospitalizations were overheaded the
woman should be fired and shamed and
never seen in public again
well just watch what we're going to do
to her here here first watch the the
part from yesterday
these are two separate thing
for counting deaths and over counting
hospitalizations as you know I covered
this closely being in the Trump White
House when this happened I talked to a
lot of Health officials about this who
are actually kind of skeptical of this
claim that you're making and I think one
big thing has been what is the evidence
that these coveted deaths are actually
being over counted
well this is the reason why this kind of
transparent reporting is going to be so
important there is a way for us to look
at death certificates and also to look
at the medical records of individuals
prior to the death and I think this
needs to be separated into three
categories one is the um the covid as a
direct contributor the primary cause of
death the second is could it be a
secondary contributing cause so for
example somebody with kidney disease
covid then pushes them over the edge to
have kidney failure that's coveted as a
contributing cause and then the third is
covet as an incidental finding so
somebody come in with a gunshot wound or
a heart attack and they happen to test
positive I think that we need to
separate out and look at the percentages
of each that percentage would have
shifted over time as well in the
beginning probably a lot more people
were dying with the primary cause of
covid that probably has shifted and I
think again we need to understand this
another reason to understand this too is
a lot of people are wondering when they
should get a booster next when do we
need a second booster or another booster
and the only way we can know for sure is
to understand who is getting severely
ill and when Connor just made a great
point that you know back in the day at
the height of kovid CNN used to have
their covid death death ticker it's
funny they don't have their death Ticker
on anymore as it's becoming obvious that
kovid was largely a hoax and now people
are dying of vaccine-related injuries
now before I fully destroy lyanna when
it is when not woo she continued this
woman still despite everything we know
about vaccines right now the fact that
they do not stop covid they do not stop
you from transmitting covid or getting
covered they actually there's no
evidence that you'll get lesser covid
even though everyone says it if you're
vaccinated there now is evidence that
you will have a vaccine injury or you
might have a heart problem or a whole
bunch more this crazy lunatic and then
trust me we're going to destroy her I
can't wait for this and then I'm taking
myself out to lunch uh this crazy
lunatic is still pushing vaccines for
pregnant women or as she calls them
pregnant individuals
you study doctor just emphasizing how at
risk pregnant women and their babies are
from from kova 19 I'm sure you saw it I
mean they tracked 13 000 pregnant women
um and I just wonder if you're concerned
for people at risk like that or other
vulnerable groups that this give can
give fodder to
um to conspiracy theorists to those who
downplay covet to anti-vaxxers I'm sure
you you know you thought about that
right as you were as you were writing
this are you worried about that
it's interesting that I have had
criticism on both sides there are people
who have said well why are you saying
that we're over counting kova does now
you should have said this two and a half
years ago that others who have said well
we're not over counting them and they
give various reasons as to why I think
at the end of the day we just need the
truth and part of that truth is what you
mentioned poppy which is that vaccines
are highly protective that vaccines are
very effective they're very safe and
vulnerable groups including pregnant
women pregnant individuals should be
getting vaccinated at the same time we
should also be honest about who was
dying from covid during the early parts
of the pandemic versus who is dying from
covenant all right first off anyone that
calls themselves a doctor
and then says the pr the phrase pregnant
individuals should have their license
revoked immediately if you've got a
penis you cannot get pregnant clip that
put that out on the internet Connor if
you have a penis you cannot get pregnant
so she she's just a charlatan altogether
but now let's destroy her let's really
destroy this woman she has lied about
absolutely everything she also says we
just need the truth that's what she just
said we just need the truth well Leon
you're right about that we do just need
the truth uh here's Leanna went about a
year and a half ago at the height of all
the craziness
people are paying a price for the
actions of the unvaccinated because what
we know is that the vaccinated are very
safe around one another so the two of
you all of us if we're vaccinated we're
safe around each other but if we're
vaccinated and we're surrounded by a
whole bunch of unvaccinated people
especially in areas with high
coronavirus transmission there's going
to be spillover and that's what we're
seeing that we're seeing vaccinated
people also get infections now they tend
to not believe severe infections which
points to the effectiveness of the
vaccine but it's possible that
especially with a Delta variant we could
still get domed we could pass it on to
our family members and so I think it's
really important that vaccinated people
stop thinking that we're fully protected
we're very well protected
okay you must understand that at first
she was saying if you were vaccinated uh
you were not going to get covered then
when it started shifting then she was
really trying to scare you if you're
vaccinated and you're with vaccinated
people somehow you're a little more
protected but if unvaccinated people get
in there you're in trouble also then
then it's not really a vaccine lady Dr
Leon Owen
um but she continued this woman she
should be fired from CNN that's not
canceled Culture by the way that's
incompetent culture if you were utterly
incompetent and if you were in complete
dereliction of your duty you should be
fired that woman should be these people
should just be put on an island
somewhere not an island where they
should be tortured really put them on
throw them to Bora Bora they can be on a
nice Island even but they just should be
removed from Human Society okay here's
Leanna Wen uh continuing this is with
Cuomo uh and she's here she is pushing
the hell out of that vaccine so that
maybe we can get back to some normalcy
do you believe that race this is the
variables are and what the messaging
should be
my main concern is that we're not going
to reach herd immunity because of
vaccine hesitancy and I know that's hard
for a lot of people to believe who
desperately want the vaccine right now
and they're thinking oh well it's just a
small percentage of people who are
actually anti-vaxxers and that's true
there is the anti-science anti-vaxxer
contingent but I think that there are
many more people millions of people who
for whatever reason have concerns about
the vaccine who just don't know what's
in it for them and we need to make it
clear to them that the vaccine is the
ticket back to pre-pandemic life and the
window to do that is really narrowing
scene is the ticket to pre-pandemic life
man is that chilling these are evil
people so this is someone who went on
all of these television shows went on
CNN she's a paid contributor of CNN got
everything wrong related to the vaccines
pushed for mandates pushed for people to
be fired if they didn't do what she
wants claimed that vaccines worked and
she's still there yesterday on CNN
talking about vaccines why does no one
get fired right it's that same thing why
is it that the machine loves people who
are wrong about everything as long as
they're wrong in the direction that the
machine wants to go I think you know the
answer to that I think you know to the
answer that it's funny we live in this
time of cancer culture where decent
people get fired for jokes they said 20
years ago and a whole bunch of other
irrelevant stuff but the people who get
all of the big stuff wrong who are
supposed to be the experts they never
get fired that woman is an AB reject
embarrassment and then you know what
happens when people like Dr Leanna
Nguyen show up on CNN and they freak
everybody out without having any
information right no no not without
having any information with
disinformation right misinformation and
they lie about all this [ __ ] they get a
whole bunch of other people who know
nothing about nothing often Hollywood
actors and actresses to say crazy things
uh we thought this would be a nice way
of uh of tying this whole thing together
this is a piece on uh I think it's on
e-entertainment Channel or something or
Hollywood extra one of these nonsensical
things uh here's Jennifer Aniston back
in August of 2021 because I get most of
my vaccine information from Jennifer
Aniston and the whole cast of Friends I
really decided my whole thing I just
went back and I watched Friends and I
thought what would these people do
during a time of pandemic but here's
Jennifer Aniston back in August of 2021
and the woman would not even have you as
a friend if you were unvaxxed Jennifer
Aniston is doubling down on cutting
non-vaccinated people out of her life
amid the covid-19 pandemic it's
something that is a part of our world
now and it does it's not going away the
52 year old actress received criticism
earlier this week after her in-style
magazine interview dropped in which she
revealed she's cut several people out of
her Inner Circle who opted to not get
the kova 19 vaccine what you resist
persists Oprah Daly shared a post to
Instagram about Jen's recent interview
and the comment section was divided to
say the least and Jen's original
statement to in style she spoke out
against quote anti-vaxxers or people she
feels quote don't listen to facts she
told the mag quote I've just lost a few
people in my weekly routine who have
refused or did not disclose whether or
not they had been vaccinated and it was
unfortunate I feel it's your moral and
and professional obligation to inform
since we're not all potted up and being
tested every single day
at some level
I have a little Sympathy for the people
like Jennifer Addison right these NPC
type people these people who believe
whatever the machine says and that's why
I'm linking it to the lyanna Wen thing
it's like if you watched CNN for the
last couple years and you didn't pay
attention to Alternative sources of news
you would start cutting people out of
your life for not being vaxxed right you
would be thinking all of the wrong
things because of people like Leanna Wen
but it's so interesting how the media
like they're trying to make her a hero
she's sort of a hero back then for
cutting people out of her life because
they got vaxxed but what would be the
reverse version of that be you think
they would ever now that we know that
the vaccines don't work that there's all
sorts of vaccine injuries that covet is
just going to kind of be here like
anything else and people will get sick
and you should do whatever seems right
for you I don't know if you have a
sniffles have some tea you know would
you think they would do a story on a
Hollywood celebrity who's like you know
what I've decided not to get vacced and
I've cut out all the vaxed people from
my life because they're brainless and
they're just you know little cogs in a
machine and I don't like them very much
and actually they do seem more sick Than
unvaccinated People you think that that
E entertainment Channel or whatever the
hell that was you think they do a story
on that
but let's bring this thing home in a
positive sort of way because the buck
stops here and I mean here what I mean
by here is with me it stops with you and
it stops right here in the Free State of
Florida uh Casey DeSantis tweeted this
out yesterday Casey Sanders of course is
the first lady of Florida Ron desantis's
wife she wrote across the country
Freedom has been stripped from the
people in the name of Public Health not
in Florida today Governor Ron DeSantis
announced he will end any remaining
unscientific restrictions permanently on
behalf of a grateful State thank you
governor and let me just get into some
of the things that you see over there in
this prescribed Freedom image that they
put up permanently prohibits covid-19
mask requirements throughout the state
permanently prohibited prohibits
covid-19 vax and mask requirements in
all schools permanently prohibits
covid-19 vaccine pass Sports in Florida
permanently prohibits employers from
hiring or firing based on mRNA jobs
protects medical professionals freedom
of speech protects the right to disagree
with the preferred Narrative of the
medical community protects the religious
views of medical professionals so do you
see what Florida is doing
now they're going to call him a
right-wing Maniac they're going to call
him an authoritarian they're going to
call him anti-science they're going to
call him all of those things but do you
see what governor Ron DeSantis did here
in the State of Florida he basically
said we are just not going to force you
to do something with your body which is
supposed to be the position of the left
right that is supposed to be my body my
choice right my penis my uterus that
thing that they're always talking about
but it's not so he is actually even
though they will say they are the people
of choice right but actually he is the
person of choice because he didn't say
you can't get faxed he didn't say you
can't wear a mask he didn't say you
can't put a Ziploc bag over your head
and wrap sir you know duct tape the
whole thing not a terrible idea for some
of these people uh he didn't say any of
those things you can do whatever you
want to do but the state will not
dictate it that is freedom that's what
it's all about
Robin just said this ladies and
gentlemen but I'll tell you uh being the
free state of Florida did not happen by
accident because it required us over
these last few years to stand against
major institutions in our society the
bureaucracy the medical establishment
Legacy Media and even the president of
the United States
[Music]
all right
who together were working to impose a
biomedical Security State on society and
the fact of the matter is they had a lot
of momentum they brought a lot of power
to these fights and they would have won
except for the fact
Florida said no
what's so beautiful about that clip
obviously what he said there we said no
the buck stops with me but if you
compare that to the world economic Forum
stuff right
um right there he has the emblem the
state flag of Florida behind him and the
emblem of Florida and the word Freedom
right in front of him it is very clear
what he cares about it is very clear who
he is here to govern who here he is here
to help keep free and it's us it's his
constituents it's the people who voted
for him and he's doing the right thing
about that it is the complete 180
reverse of what these people are doing
in Davos right they don't care about
individual Freedom they don't care about
the United States they certainly don't
care about Florida they care about their
ability to attain power and how they can
exercise that power over you and you
know what that even goes as far as
making sure that you can't breathe fresh
air because they don't want you to
breathe fresh air they would love to
have you in masks all the time but it
ain't happening here in the Free State
of Florida
we also believe that being able to live
your life being able to breathe the
fresh air is something that should
basically be a civil right uh you should
not have to have any of these mask
requirements imposed on you yes Florida
will not do it of course
yeah again you can wear a mask if you
want for the rest of your life you can
and every now and again even here in
Florida I see people still sometimes
even Outdoors wearing a mask and guess
what you can you can whatever you want
to wear you can wear it you like your
little diaper your little chin diaper
wear your little chin diaper uh DeSantis
went on to talk a bit more about some of
the plans that he has in place these
protections around our freedoms from
that Casey DeSantis tweet
and even today
Biden and his lawyers at the Department
of Justice were in federal court in
Miami trying to get reimposed the mask
mandate for airline passengers which a
district judge had struck down last year
even after all of this they still want
to put you back in masks when you fly on
a commercial airline some of these
people just won't quit they've imposed
vac or mask mandates on school children
and some of these enclaves throughout
the United States there's no turning
back from our direction we need to
continue to lead and we need to lead
with this
foreign
we need to lead with this by making all
of these protections permanent in
Florida statute which we are going to do
in the upcoming legislative session
you really need to understand how
important this is and I know I talk a
little awful lot about Florida I think
it's warranted
because he now has super majorities in
the Florida legislature they can make
this stuff permanent and the federal
government will not be able to at least
as the Constitution stands as it does
stand out and I know the Constitution is
under attack and I know the globalists
would love to have hate speech laws and
everything else which our Constitution
and our Bill of Rights protects against
but Florida is proactively not just not
just waiting for things to happen we are
proactively going out there and saying
the next version of this which is coming
whether it's covid-19 or whether it's
monkey pox or whether it's climate
lockdowns we are not going to force
people to do things we will not bow to
the biomedical Security State so that is
why when good people step up you must
back them and you must get some skin in
the game but think about how seriously
Twisted guys seriously Twisted it is
that you may remember it was it was
under a year ago it was less than a year
ago I believe it was May because I had
just started my book tour and I wasn't
that thrilled to get on all these planes
and travel across the country having to
wear a mask on the plane and about two
days before the tour started a judge a
35 year old Trump appointed judge in uh
was it uh in Tampa her name is Catherine
Kimball mizelle everyone should know her
name this woman is a hero she reversed
just just like that she reversed the
Mandate on planes to force you to wear
masks on planes and then you know what
happened the next day everybody took
their masks off for the most part right
and guess what there were no massive
covet outbreaks and everything else and
people started smiling again it got much
overnight it got much more pleasant to
be in an airport because if you were at
an airport or on a plane during covet it
was absolutely miserable you could feel
the hostility I don't have to tell you
you all know it yourselves right the the
hero of kovid became the guy who was
smoking the uh the French fry remember
one guy he took it he literally for
three hours on a flight I love this
fried potato I have to have it in my
mouth the whole time I mean that is the
stupidity that they pushed on us but one
Trump appointed 35 year old woman she's
just one woman she reversed the freaking
thing and the Biden Administration now
now is trying to reinstate it and they
are fighting for that in court the Biden
Administration also extended their covet
emergency see Powers the same type of
[ __ ] that Palpatine did okay watch the
prequels I keep telling you they're
looking better over time anyway guys
I think we laid out a pretty solid case
today uh I want to thank everybody for
for watching and interacting with us and
everything else our numbers have just
been bananas almost every day we're
breaking every previous number like
things are really exploding across the
board uh I I hope that you guys find
this valuable I suppose that you do we
will keep doing it we will not stop I
think we're doing the right thing it
feels good to do the right thing and uh
and I hope you're doing the right thing
whatever that means to you uh we got a
cold close for you just a moment and
then of course we do have the post game
show uh so if you want to join the post
game show
reubenreport.locals.com post game show
coming up
momentarily says Republicans are faking
outrage on this issue why shouldn't
Americans be outraged about classified
documents being found in a garage look
and I think I've been very clear about
this we have answered questions on this
at this Podium you've heard as Phil was
saying twice from the president talk
about this he said that he didn't know
right he said that he was surprised and
he said that he takes classified
information and documents very very
seriously we heard directly from the
president on this issue
foreign
[Music]